I am Daniel Desjardins and I am a scout master with through 426 in
London Dairy, New Hampshire. This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored
by backers like me And now the old scout master.
So there we are at summer camp. First day scouts are headed out. The senior
patrol leader notices one of the younger scouts is walking a little
awkwardly and so he stops him and he says: you having a problem
there or something? You don't look very comfortable. And he says:
and the scout looks at him and says: Well, you know, it's kind
of hard to wear seven pairs of socks at the same time. The
senior patrol leader shakes his head and he says: What do you
mean? seven pairs of socks at the same time? Why are you wearing
seven pairs of socks? And the scout says: Well, I know we're
supposed to change socks every day, But to save time I'm just
going to wear them all and I'll take one pair off every morning.
Oh my, yes, masters of time and motion studies, these scouts
aren't they? Hey, this is podcast number 230..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's take a look at the mailbag and see what's going on out there. Oh, let's see, we had a new review from SCJ about my book, the scouting journey, posted on Amazoncom, And it says: great summary, takes much of the old scouting literature, summarizing
It, puts it in a language that's easy to understand. Well, great, I'm glad that that worked. I've purchased several copies to give to my fellow scouts, who are all on the same page when it comes to managing the troop. Well, I think that's fantastic. And if you're not familiar with it, my book, the scouting journey, it's available on Amazon. It's also available at scoutmastercgcom in an ebook version that actually includes my other book, thoughts on scouting. So go to scoutmastercgcom and check that out. And thank you,
SCJ, whoever you are, for that wonderful review. Now, as you've learned for the past several weeks, if I'm working on the blog and I'm working at my desk and I have the time, I will turn on the live chat at scoutmastercgcom. I heard from Daniel Dominguez this past week. he said I found you looking for information about
scouting. I am from Paraguay, South America. Keep up the good work. Very interesting information. Be prepared, which, in Paraguay, I happen to know because I met some scouts from Paraguay. I think it was at the 1989 National Jamboree. if you want to go back that far. Be prepared is siempre listo. How about that? I remembered it.
Craig Dixon is a scoutmaster from Troop 682 in Poway, California, And he said: I came across an article that sums up why many of us are scouts, And it is a great article and I'll make sure to link to it in the post that contains this podcast And I want to quote from the article. if you have some stability and love in your life, sooner or later you'll probably have the experience of being nominated by a child from a troubled family to nurture them.
You're not asked to be nominated, nor will your input be sought on the selection, because the child is a nominating committee of one. And, Craig, I appreciate you pointing that article out to me because it does express something that we don't often talk about. But I think that we all understand we all get just so many opportunities in life to make a difference And a lot of times will be nominated to make a difference, not by some extensive selection committee or something like that, but by the heart of a child who needs our help
And recognizing that we have been nominated. that's a pretty big deal. So thanks, Craig, for that thought. Craig also went on to say that he's been enjoying the horseshoe webcam And you know what? I'll put up a link so that you can check it out too. And next week you can see me at summer camp maybe. but the camp that we'll be attending, it has a webcam that's on all summer,
And Craig was there in the 1970s, even though he's out in California now. So we share that little point of reference in common, don't we? Thanks once again, Craig, for getting in touch and sharing that article.
I also heard from Sergio Ricardo Carey, who is with Scout Troop SP02 in San Paulo, Florida, Brazil, And he wrote to say: I'm a scout leader and I've been reading some of the articles at scoutmastercgcom sent to me by one of my old scout leaders.
I'm also a translator from English to Portuguese here in Brazil. I believe some of your articles would be useful for Brazilian scout leaders. Would you be interested in having the articles translated into Portuguese? I'd love to help and spread my knowledge among my colleagues.
Well, I certainly would, Sergio, And I've been. well, I did reply to Sergio and he's going to translate some of the articles I've written into Portuguese for Brazilian scouts. I'm just so pleased about that,
And if you've been listening to the podcast for a while. you know that sometimes I have enough trouble with English, let alone Portuguese. But I'm glad the message is getting out there And I'm so happy that Sergio's volunteered to help us with that. Thank you, Sergio.
Also heard from Thomas Kepley, who said I was referred to your site by my cousin and a backer of yours, Gant Edmondson. I have two boys in scouting who are 10 and 12 years old and I've been involved as an assistant cubmaster and treasurer of our Cub Scout pack, But now I've been tapped to serve as scoutmaster of the Boy Scout Troop that my boys will be part of.
I want to be involved, but I'm a little concerned about the time involved in this commitment and my lack of experience in scouting. I've begun listening to your podcast, or there's certain ones you suggest I put on my first listen list.
First of all, Tom, thanks for finding us And thank you, Gant, for recommending the blog and the podcast to your cousin there. I don't really have a list of what you should start listening to first,
But I'm sure once you start looking around on the blog and look at the podcast archive you'll pick out some subjects that you'd like to become more familiar with, And congratulations on the idea of becoming a scoutmaster
Around here. we call it jumping into the volcano And it's nice and warm down here. So you know, come in, join us.
Michael Grow writes to us from Lake Arrowhead, California. I volunteer at Forest Lawn Scout Reservation teaching astronomy and radio merit badges.
I contacted you about a year ago about putting the podcast on our camp radio station And we currently are broadcasting them at 7am and 5pm Monday through Friday.
I want to thank you for all your efforts in serving the scouting community.
Our website is flsrradioorg where you can listen to the radio station stream- And I did, And it's really cool.
You know they have a real radio station and it's broadcasting and you can stream it live and check it out. It's flsrradioorg.
Thanks for sharing the podcast with everybody there at Forest Lawn Scout Reservation.
Well, it is summertime and next week I'm off to scout camp. That's right. On Sunday I'm off to camp for the week
And, if all goes according to plan, all next week you'll get a letter from camp every day. That's right, Every single day.
I know scouts don't do that reliably, but I'm going to do my best to post a letter from summer camp every day.
So keep an eye on scoutmastercgcom. You can go over there and you can register to get updates to the blog by email
And that way you'll be able to keep up with me. next week. I won't be publishing a formal regular scoutmaster podcast next week,
Just so that you know. we're going to let the podcast take a little rest, but I will be sending you a letter every day from scout camp,
So make sure you tune in for that. Before we move on into the rest of the podcast, let me answer this question for you.
How do we make all this happen? Well, as you heard at the beginning of this week's podcast, we have backers based on a very simple premise:
If you find what we're offering is helping you in your work as a scouter, you can return the favor by joining the growing number of scouts who financially support the creation of these resources by becoming backers.
Go to scoutmastercgcom, click on the support link at the top of the page and you'll learn how you can help.
And within this past week, I want to make sure to take the time to thank Eric Gilliam personally for becoming a backer last week.
It really matters and it really does count. So thank you very much, Eric.
In this week's podcast in Scout Master'ship, in seven minutes or less. we're going to talk a little bit about what I call the internal standard that we're working to create in our scouts,
And then I've got an email question to answer, so that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast. Let's get started, shall we?
Scout Master'ship in seven minutes or less.
Just yesterday- this is Sunday- in a feature that we call Baden Powell's blog, where we're posting something that Sir Robert Baden Powell, the founder of the worldwide scouting movement, wrote during his lifetime,
And the title of this week's post was The Other Fellow's Point of View,
And I want to quote from that a little bit to introduce the idea of an internal standard to you.
Baden Powell wrote: we in the Scouts desire not so much to cure present social evils as to prevent their reoccurrence in the rising generation.
If our lads were trained as a regular habit to see The Other Fellow's Point of View before passing their own judgment on a dispute, what a difference it would make.
So just this idea, this one aspect of character, of understanding The Other Fellow's Point of View, got me to thinking about what defines the character that we're trying to inspire.
What is it that we can do for our scouts so that they have the capacity, as Baden Powell said, they are trained as a regular habit to see The Other Fellow's Point of View before passing their own judgment.
And I think that the character we are trying to inspire is perfectly defined in the Scout Oath and Law.
It doesn't really need any more embroidering than that.
The Scout Oath and Law stand pretty much on their own as an expression of values and ideals that have been the common currency of every enlightened human society throughout history.
How about that? I mean, that's a pretty big claim, isn't it?
How do we affect our scouts? How do we accomplish the idea of getting them to internalize the Scout Oath and Law?
So it's something that, throughout the rest of their lives, that they can call on as they set their path in life.
And I would say we do that by creating opportunities for our scouts to exercise their understanding of the Scout Oath and Law,
To build this internal standard of ideals and conduct that, as Baden Powell said, don't so much cure present social evils as prevent their recurrence in the rising generation.
So what opportunities do we create? Well, just everything that scouts do, of course, will give them experiences that call upon that an internal standard:
Working together as a patrol and going camping and meetings and doing everything that scouts do. they have to call continuously on that internal standard to be able to listen to the other fellow's point of view
and to make good judgments and good choices about the way that they're going to approach things and the way that they're going to behave.
There are other really important opportunities that sometimes we may miss. One of them is Scoutmaster Conferences.
In the advancement scheme that is followed by the Boy Scouts of America, prior to advancing in every rank you have to have had a Scoutmaster Conference,
And there's a lot of verbiage about Scoutmaster Conferences, but basically what it is is very simply sitting down with a scout and having a discussion with them about scouting and about their progress in scouting.
And as we do that, if we ask them some questions, we get them to begin to exercise the internal standard that we want to build
By inquiring about their understanding of the ScoutOath and Law.
And the more practical we can be with those questions, the better.
The more we can refer to things that they have participated in and that have happened to them, the better we can build on that internal standard.
Now, as a matter of course, many of us at a Scoutmaster's Conference are also signing off a couple of common requirements to every rank.
One is Scout Spirit and Active Participation
And also their understanding of several points of the Scout Law in the ranks up to first class.
In the more senior ranks we're talking about the way they've performed in a position of responsibility.
So the best way to begin to exercise that internal standard, that standard of judgment that we want them to carry through the rest of their lives,
is to ask them how they judge themselves against those requirements.
Do they think they've met those requirements? Why do they think they've met them?
How does the ScoutOath and Law bear on the conduct that they have exhibited over the past period of time since our last Scoutmaster Conference?
It's a very rich field of inquiry and, handled correctly,
It's a wonderful way to build that internal standard.
Another really great opportunity for us is when the Patrol Leaders Council is gathered.
Our role as Scoutmasters at the Patrol Leaders Council is principally listening,
And when you listen what you'll hear is you'll hear Scouts exercising that internal standard that we're building according to the ScoutOath and Law.
You'll hear them solving problems and making plans and commenting on the way things are going,
And occasionally the opportunity will be presented for you to ask a great question that calls on that internal standard, their understanding of the ScoutOath and Law.
You're not offering your understanding of it, quite so much as calling on them to make their own judgments according to their understanding of the ScoutOath and Law.
If they ask you what you think, well, then you have the opportunity to share that.
But instead of making statements or making judgments, if we ask questions that probe their understanding, we're really going to exercise that internal standard.
Now we do have an opportunity to make statements and to define that standard in the Scoutmaster Minute
And so paying attention to that and making sure that it's a meaningful and understandable and brief, because you get a minute and a minute is 60 seconds, it's not 90 seconds.
You know what I say. you've got their attention for so much time, so make it count.
But you can talk about that internal standard,
You can talk about stories that demonstrate it and build on those principles.
So, just to review this concept and this way of looking at things,
Our aim is to build character, and character comes from internalizing the ideals and values that are expressed in the ScoutOath and Law,
And each one of us needs to internalize that individually
And there are several ways for Scoutmasters to exercise that internal standard,
As I said in Scoutmasters conferences, at the Patrol Leaders Council meeting and during Scoutmaster Minutes,
In a way that bring these things to the surface and provide Scouts with the opportunity to exercise their understanding of these things.
You're my favorite all time boy scout.
You are always on the beat boy, beat boy. yeah, You are always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'll hang you in the sweet boy, sweet boy.
You're my favorite all time boy scout.
I have one great email question to answer this week and this email question comes
from David. He says I was wondering when did the troop guide become a position of responsibility
in scouting And why was it installed? I'm guessing it might have been a countermeasure
for adults wanting to mix up the patrols with various aged scouts. We have a new scout master
who wants to reorganize patrols to help with the training of younger scouts. Of course,
my scouts have been together for two and a half years and some longer through Cubs.
I'd hate to see their patrol split up when they've been together for this long, and I
would really hate to see any group of friends split up. Well, David, I hate to see
that too. but let me tell you what my remembrance of the history of the
establishment of the troop guide position is, And if you're not familiar with it,
the troop guide position is basically a position of responsibility in which a
scout helps guide a patrol of younger scouts. And as I remember, this position
of responsibility was established about 20 years ago as part of the first class in
the first year initiative And the logic behind that initiative was that a leading
indicator in membership retention is reaching first class within the first
year. So it was suggested to scouts that this was a really good idea and it
could be done by keeping scouts together in a patrol of scouts basically their
own age. And this began with what was called the new scout patrol And this was a
group of scouts bridging over from Weeblos- And if you're not familiar with
Weeblos, that is the oldest division of Cub Scouts- And the tradition in the
BSA is that once they've completed the two years of Weeblos they then join
a scout troop And it was the habit at the time and it remains the habit of a
lot of scout troops to take those younger boys and divide them up into
existing patrols of older scouts. And research showed 20 years ago that that
wasn't working out very well because it resulted in the attrition of a lot of
those younger scouts And it was more promising to keep them together in
their same age group. And to address the concern that a young patrol would
have a lot of difficulty getting by, the position of troop guide was
created, an older, experienced scout who was not functioning as the patrol
leader but as a guide for the younger scouts who elected their own
patrol leader and had their own patrol. Now I don't think this was
strictly a countermeasure for adults monkeying around with patrols, but as
an encouragement to create conditions that made it more likely to retain
members by providing a better experience for younger scouts. Some
scouts seem to think that this works very well and they use this kind
of new patrol concept today And some scouts use some kind of
adaptation of it. My standard advice that determining who is in what
patrol is up to the Patrol Leaders Council And they do that
according to the wishes of the scouts themselves And those
wishes are most often going to be based on ages and friendships.
Now I can understand why any scout master would think they
could do a better job of setting up patrols and mixing up the ages
and, you know, kind of balancing things out, But I think that's a
misguided approach. Boys become scouts for one principal reason,
And that is to go camping and do fun stuff with their friends.
Anything else that happens is great, But from a boy's point of
view, they are scouts for that one reason. In my experience,
you don't increase the efficacy of training younger scouts by
assigning patrols in the way that you think it's going to work
best, by mixing up the ages and moving scouts away from their
friends. This really ends up creating more problems than it
solves. I've tried a lots of different ideas about the
composition of patrols And many years ago tried assigning
scouts to patrols by my own best lights And it never really
worked. Friendships and peer groups are much stronger than any
assignment that I can make, And what I found was within the
first few minutes of a troop meeting or a camping trip,
scouts disregarded my patrol assignments to be with their
friends or with their peer group. It was, you know. you
would look up and maybe they lined up and started the
meeting with their patrol And that was fine. But as soon as
the meeting got going, they all kind of gravitated towards
their friends or they gravitated towards their peer group and
the patrols weren't really functioning And this put me in
the continual position of breaking up those natural
groups into the patrols I had set up. And of course that's
pretty frustrating because I had to do it all the time And
it didn't make me happy and it didn't make the scouts
happy. What I finally learned was, instead of fighting the
power of friendships and peer groups, that it was better
to leverage that power. Instead of creating problems for
ourselves by trying to assign scouts to patrols that they
don't really want to be in, I think it's more effective to
work with the patrols that they form themselves. If we do
that and focus on instilling the idea in our older
scouts that they are responsible for the younger
scouts, that they ought to be working with them and
training them continuously, we find things work a lot
better and that our scouts are happier and therefore
we're happier right, This sense of responsibility in the
older scouts. it can take some time to create, but once
created, it does pretend to perpetuate itself. So when
scouts ask me, how do I set up patrols? You know, my
standard advice is: you don't let the scouts take care of
that and then deal with what they set up And if they
create problems in the way they set up patrols, help
them unravel the problems. And a lot of people are very
resistant to that advice because they think, well,
scouts will just do it by popularity or by their
friends and somebody will be left out. Well, you
know, it all comes in how you approach this question
with them. Everyone needs to be included, nobody's
left out. You need to form patrols as you see fit
and then we'll solve any problems that your
decisions create. And in my experience there are
going to be many fewer problems than you would
expect. If people are still resistant to this
idea, I asked them how they would think about
this scenario. Let's pretend that I am the
commissioner for all the scout troops in your
town and I've been empowered to maximize the
efficiency of training and effectiveness among
scouts. So I'm going to reassign some of the
scouts from your troop to a troop across town
where they'll have a better effect. This means
that I'll be sending a few of your pals from
your troop to another troop across town and
I'll be bringing some of those guys over to
your troop just to balance things out, just
to make training more effective, Because some
of you guys, you're pretty new at this and you
don't really know what you're doing. They have
a lot of guys who are older, So we're going to
mix it all up. How would that make you feel? Now,
you might not be able to go camping with your
son, but you know we're trying to do the
best interest of the program and scouting. It
may break up a few friendships, but you
know you guys will deal with it because
it's the most efficient way of doing things. Now,
if I was able to do that and I came to
your troop and I talked to you and your
assistant scout masters, how would you
feel? You wouldn't go along with it, would
you? You'd be pretty upset about it, and
rightfully so. I'd imagine you'd fight
this sort of thing or, you know, in lieu
of that, simply give up on scouting all
together. That's exactly how scouts feel
if you start working against their
friendships or ignoring their peer
groups. They feel the same way. You're
stepping in and breaking up things that
are important to them, in the same way
that that, commissioner, would be stepping
in and breaking up things that you feel
are important. I think that once you see
it from the scout's perspective, you're
going to be a lot more careful about
the methods that you employ to form
patrols. David, I hope that all helps. If
you have a question, you can get in
touch with me and you're going to
find out how to do that in just a
moment.
Well, thank you so much for listening to
this 230th edition of the
Scoutmaster podcast. Here's how to keep
in touch.
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom and,
while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by
email. You can get the Scoutmaster
app on Google Play or at the iTunes
App Store and have all the resources
we create right there at your
fingertips on your mobile device. You
can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media outlets. Join
the 6300 folks who like Scoutmaster
blog on Facebook. tweet along with the
course of 1100 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the Pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly with 1600 other
prolific pinners on Pinterest and
watch us, if you dare, at Scoutmaster
CG on YouTube, And especially next
week, you're going to get a letter from
summer camp every day if things go
according to plan, And you can join the
400 odd folks who form the exclusive
Scoutmaster circle on Google Plus.
Yes, Google Plus, it's still there.
People still go there every once in a
while. But listen,
Bunky. if you can't face Facebook, if
Twitter makes you better, if you have
no interest in Pinterest, if you don't
put the? U in YouTube, if you're a
minus when it comes to Google Plus,
zoom into the late 90s and send me an
email. Yes, you can email me, Clark
Green, your questions and comments.
wild ideas at Clark at
scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E at
scoutmastercgcom. And it should come
as no surprise that the Scoutmaster
podcast and the Scoutmaster blog and
all the other things we do are not
official publications of the Boy Scouts
of America, nor are they endorsed or
sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter.
Nope, it's just me talking into a
microphone trying to lend a hand to
Scoutleaders and, you know, have a
little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun, here's our
founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir
Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir, Until next time,
everyone.